so this weekend if you were going to arm
a screenwriter with just one weapon or
tool
what would that be what would that one
tool or weapon be
well um at my school
at how movies work in venice the one
thing i tell
beginning writers is um
if you if you want to succeed
you've got to tell a story that you
personally love and that matters to you
personally and it has to come out of
some deep place in yourself
if you try to write commercially or try
them right to the market you're going to
fail i see it all the time oh
i got to write a superhero story so i'm
going to write it this is true for guys
by the way who want to write action
who say i want to be the next tarantino
you know i don't care about
you know jacobian character that doesn't
matter to me i love lasers and guns and
stuff
it doesn't matter i've got 18 year olds
in my in my classes
who can quote every line of star wars
which is a 45 year old movie
and it's not because of the laser fights
or even the wookie or whatever
it's because that the story of luke
was the story of george lucas and he
passionately wanted to tell the story of
a kid
from out in the sticks with a great
powerful force inside him that he wasn't
using it he had to go somewhere and
change himself
and use that gift the force that was
why that movie succeeded not because it
was a space opera
passion about your story the truth about
yourself
on the page is the most important
gift you have as a writer people say
that's not true peter i'm a boar there's
nothing in me that's interesting
and what i say to that is i bet there's
something you did in the last 24 hours
that you would hate any of us to see
some terribly embarrassing thing about
yourself some pain about yourself
you need to write about the pain and
pleasure and the dreams you have of your
own life
don't say that to cliche every great
movie
ever made comes from that passion
comes from the writer's passion and love
for that story there's only seven
stories in the world
they've all been told a thousand times
the only thing you've got as a writer
is your passion your love your
experience that's what makes you
different than anybody else and what
makes your story different from anybody
else
and people can people i see hipsters who
go now that's not true i'm going to make
them
i'm going to make a cool story about
violence it's just about guns it's just
about knives it's about the cool stuff
that happens
and i'm going to say you're going to
fail that's not going to succeed
tarantino doesn't make movies like that
he makes movies that speak to him from
his heart
that are from his secret desires our
secret desires
our secret pleasures our secret pains
that's what motivates all great story
always
and it always will that's all you've got
as a human being to distinguish yourself
from
from anybody else so it has to come from
there
and you can learn the form i can teach
you the form at how movies work
i can show you the rhythms but if you
don't have them inside of yourself
you're going to get bored and you're
going to quit so let's say you have a
student come back to you and they say
this is it this is what's inside of me
and you say you know what i'm calling bs
on this
this isn't right i do that all the time
how can you tell
oh instantly look hello let me tell you
something okay here's another secret
about myself
um i killed a monkey in high school with
a drill
no that's not true and you could tell
it's not true
you can tell when somebody's telling you
the truth about themselves you always
know
you knew that story about my lips was
true i when i read a script
and someone tells me about them being a
cia agent in pakistan and killing
somebody
i can tell if they're actually just
sitting on their couch in in
thousand oaks and they've never been to
pakistan and they've never been in the
state
i know instantly when the page is lying
how do you know that because we all have
this
built-in bs detector when people make
stuff up
we know it when people tell us the truth
about their lives
we know it we can tell and we're
interested
that's the key distinction i tell you if
you're going to write me a story about a
guy
in pakistan who's in the ca and as a spy
you better have been in pakistan
as a cia spy or spent about 10 years
living in the world of those who did it
are you going to tell me a story that's
going to bore the
pants off of me it's not going to feel
real at
all that's how you know you always tell
the truth
in a fictional story you just put it in
a rhythm
and you expand on it and if you don't
have the gumption
to confess the embarrassing truths about
yourself
confess them about somebody else that
you know really intimately because
everyone's weird and we all know weird
things about other people
but they must come from the truth or you
will
fail you're going to bore your audience
they're going to know it's not true that
scene i told you about in superbad where
he confesses that when he was 11
he drew penises in class and he had a
whole
lunch box full of of what he called dick
drawings
that scene is funny and hilarious and
it's simple we're sympathetic to this
guy because we know the writer that
actually happened to the writer it's
excruciating to see it on the screen
but it's got the ring of truth why
because we're all weird
we've done so many weird things in our
lives that we've never wanted anybody to
know
i have you have you have
and that's what we draw on that's what
we want to know about you that's why
gossip
is stuff we really want to hear oh
you're going to tell me something that's
gossip
oh i want to hear why because it's
embarrassing it's true and it's weird
that's every great story
you